si papa noël quand tu descendras 10 avec
une chorale dans la grande salle du
château d'amboise le monument royal se
met au diapason de la saison hivernale
et des fêtes de fin d'année à travers
une crèche napolitaine des jouets
anciens et les sapins décorés ce fleuron
des châteaux de la loire joue son rôle
de livres d'histoire à la renaissance ce
qui est manifeste c'est qu'il y a une
influence italienne extrêmement forte
cela touche par exemple à la crèche la
première commande de crèches qui est
réalisé à la cour de france va être
formulée par la soeur du roi charles ix
8 donc à un moment où amboise c'est
vraiment le coeur du royaume
[Musique]
et de la même façon donc au 19e siècle
ce château propriété d orient est
associé à diffusion d'un élément
symbolique de noël sapins de noël
ce sapin de noël il est introduit en
france à la faveur de la présence de
l'épousé de fils aîné du roi
louis-philippe une princesse allemande
qui va amener cette tradition du sapin
de noël aux tuileries et dans les
châteaux de la pop des propriétés de la
famille derrière la présentation des
traditions de noël à travers les siècles
il ya aussi la volonté d'offrir à une
clientèle familiale réunis pour les
fêtes une animation attractive en termes
de visites seul esprit du moment c'est
ce que recherchent les gens des décors
merveilleux ils veulent faire partager à
leurs enfants
la magie de noël d'enfance c'est
important la transmission entre
générations et en à avoir en rotant et
surtout à sentir ce sont des vrais sympa
[Applaudissements]